[Music]
on today's show we have a special
father's day episode where i talk about
your stories about some of your dad's
i even call my old man and man that
apple hit the tree all
the way down we also take a couple of
calls talk to a young man who's learning
how to grieve with his wife
we talked to a young leader who's having
to lean into some hard conversations at
work
stay tuned
what's up
[Music]
this is john with the doctor john
deloney show
when you called me up this morning told
me about the new love you found
i said i'm happy for you oh i'm really
happy for you
that song has been stuck in my head ever
since we did it on the show
kelly's eyebrows are really high either
she's like ugh i wish a guy would sing
that to me
or she's thinking ah i made a tragic
career mistake
joining this show what's the first
option or go with the second option i
know
hey listen this is a special father's
day edition show
plus a couple of calls that really don't
have anything to do with father's day
but
wanted to shout out father's day um
so we did an instagram thing oh i if you
want to be on the show give us a shout
at um one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one
or go to ask john ramseysolutions.com
johndelony.com
there's a 50 ways there's not 50 ways
there's three ways that you can do it
right um one eight 1-844-693-3291
join us on our show so i did a thing on
instagram
i just asked hey tell me your favorite
dad stories your favorite
dad advice and here are some things that
we got
we've got some fantastic stuff um
dad's stories included my dad
always making sure we were well taken
care of it's not a story but it's great
evening family meetings quote unquote
with my brother and me
my dad told us this ongoing episodic
story
every night i love that
on a dc trip my dad took me to see 21
jump street instead of any sort of
monument or anything way to go dad
um you're the reason we're having civil
civic implosion across the country but i
hope the movie was funny
i do like jonah hillman he's good my
five-year-old son dumped a full
five-gallon bucket of used motor oil on
my driveway
that's all it says i don't really know
what that means
i don't know if you were confused as to
what a dad is um
yikes all right um
my older brother once asked at bedtime
if werewolves were real
my dad paused and said yep good night
close the door that dad is dead of the
century
um cool thing about being a dad is when
my 18 year old comes home and tells me
i'm a good dad and a good example to
follow that's outstanding
an absentee dad had flowers delivered
once to my school on my sixth birthday
and had the principal call me on the
intercom
i don't know if that's terrible for a
six-year-old or incredible
for me it would have been cool i imagine
my
wife would have just turned into would
have spontaneously come busted
um but those are cool so here's some dad
oh here's my favorite dad's story i
actually pulled it up on the old
cellular device here check it out
father's day story
when we had our first baby my husband
was so set on being the perfect dad
and following everything by the book
that he created a tracking system to
write down my breastfeeding
he wrote out which side ounces in time
of day to ensure i was switching it up
correctly
when the milk came in which nobody
warned anybody about
he created his own dairy farm system to
ensure i was comfortable
and to help ease the pain everyone said
he was a crazy hover dad
they were correct seven years later we
laugh about it and he's the most amazing
dad so proud to call him my husband and
the father of
my children listen
you're a better person than me that
sounds like a lot
how was your spreadsheet system james
not so effective
i think with the first kid we've you
know there was some app we used and then
by the time
we got to the last one i was like ah
we'll we'll just wing it
just hey there's there's there's some
diet coke and cigarettes in the fridge
just figure it out that's james's kid
well hey um father with the tracking
system
god bless you and more importantly god
bless the wife that's still married to
you that's awesome
all right some good and dad advice here
we go men are like greyhound buses
another one will be along in 15 minutes
turn off the life when light so when you
leave a room i'm always telling my kids
to leave
turn the lights off don't date a guy
that can't give a good handshake you
don't want to wet
noodle all your life yes yes
show up and be in the moment that sounds
like a hippie thing i would say good for
you
give warm eye contact and show emotional
vulnerability
where are these dads coming from things
get messier before they get
tidy that sounds like it's from a
calendar
if you start out i took this the wrong
way
if you start out on third base and i
went well that's not a conversation i've
ever had with my dad
but it was not it says if you start out
on third base don't act like you hit a
triple
well played learn to drive everything
you never know when you'll have to steal
a random vehicle and run
way to go dad never
spit in a man's face unless his beard is
on fire
okay buy it right the first time and you
only cry once
excellent don't walk through the house
in your underwear
some things can't be unseen that sounds
like advice given to a dad
don't date till you're married
that was cool in 1844 it's okay to
litter because the birds will pick it up
and use
it for their nests not great
don't do anything that sounds like my
dad don't do anything stupid and don't
let
those around you do anything stupid get
a job like a real adult
measure three times cut once use the
best tool not the closest tool
save 15 as soon as you start working
you'll never
miss it nothing good happens after
midnight these are all dad things
don't ever use your blinker it's no one
else's business where you're going
that's funny terrible advice but funny
make friends with your pain and tell it
how your day is going to go
i i think my dad
sit let's call him hey can we call my
dad
let's call him
he's probably not gonna answer
hello what's up man
that's not a 600 number that's a nice
number
i really didn't answer it you sound as
joyful as always good to talk to you
well i'm in the middle of one of my
saddest things i do in a year but most
important things i'm
actually in a conference on crimes
against women it's the largest in the
world and uh
it's a very difficult couple of weeks
yeah
as is i just came off a whole semester
of teaching domestic violence and we
we did not laugh the entire semester
well thank man
good to talk to you one of my great
great one of my great passions
is uh taking care of victims
yeah and i'm blessed to be able to teach
domestic violence intimate partner
violence from in utero through
geriatrics
so the span of
victimization is
amazing yeah it's pretty pretty awful
well i just wanted to call and tell you
happy father's day and i'm glad you're
my dad
well i'm glad you're still out there
learning about
things that most people spend their
whole life not wanting to get involved
with
and that you're willing to wade into
garbage it's been a good example for me
because that's what i do for a living so
well it's uh
sneaking up on the 45-year mark of law
enforcement and now in the uh
university context it's a one of my
goals in life
is to learn something every day and uh
and certainly how to encourage people on
their journeys
well that's awesome well you did a good
job with me i think
i think you i think you got a solid b
plus
on this guy well
uh parenting was where i first
began to understand grace from a
spiritual context
because
if i could put up with y'all then
god could probably put up with me i
think you got that the wrong way
i think that's where we learned grace is
watching how much you screwed up
and how good we all still turned out but
whatever
well yeah yeah of course
you have to
land on your feet that's what i'm out on
top
that's the essence of negotiation well
played
all right man hey get back to that hard
stuff you're getting into
and uh i love you and i'm glad that
you're my old man and uh y'all go have
fun
i love you too and uh uh your mom
probably does too
so uh on the weekdays
yeah we uh i think
you mentioned to some of your crew that
we just recently uh
uh stepped into the 51st year of
marriage now
and it's still a a
delightful journey and adventure and
i i would use a lot of words to describe
that it would not be delightful
uh well it's a continuous look
at the old star trek thing where that
rocket just shoots into the future and
you don't know
what the heck's gonna happen all right
bye
bye y'all have fun all right you too
what a baller
[Laughter]
i wish a hundred percent of our
conversations are like that
where he's really cool and you're really
disrespectful not that at all
where it goes hey how's it going i'm
learning about domestic violence and how
i can better help people how are you
it's like i totally love your dad right
now i mean i met him but i'm
that was that was just fabulous well
happy father's day everybody
i'm not gonna want to go hang out with
him man he's a cool guy but anyway
so what what tell the story about when
you first became a father
oh yeah so when i found out i was going
to be a dad
i kind of we went through so so long
of you know of not being able to have
kids and then suddenly
like hey this is happening and i googled
how to be a good dad
it was like a midnight and i was kind of
i have a heart race and i googled how to
be a good dad
and i just clicked this is why you never
google things by the way
of meaning google how to fix your car
how to replace a bumper and what good
chinese food is in your area
do not google how to be a good dad
because here's what came up
i pull up the first article and it went
through some really extraordinary men
in women in history this person
accomplished this this person
accomplished this and i'm i'm thinking
yeah
yeah yeah and then it ended with
all of these people had in common dads
that either abandoned their families or
died some tragic death young and so the
best thing you can do for your kid
is to die young into or to abandon them
and that was yeah it's i just remember
thinking no no there's got to be other
things
and there are like showing up and being
vulnerable
and getting up again and again and again
and like my dad said still trying to
learn something new every day
and especially wading into things when
they're hard and messy and messy and
hard
oh man being a dad has been the greatest
hardest adventure of my whole life
yours too james i love it yeah i love
it i do think based on that list of
things we read earlier those that that
advice we're going to have
jobs on this show for a long time there
should be plenty of of colors
of trauma to unpack especially
tell us a story about your dad my son
dumped a full five-gallon bucket of
motor oil on the driveway
that's that sounds like a dad just saw
it and it's like i'll tell you a story
that's the most dead thing
is to be asked a question and be
answered completely different
good job dad good job all right let's
take a couple of calls here before we
wrap up
let's go to uh matthew in jackson
mississippi what's up matthew how are we
doing man
i'm doing well how are you doing john
i'm doing good so what's up brother how
can i help
all right so uh me and my wife got
married in the
middle of 2020 um i'm 24 and she's 23.
uh and through since then we've gone
through
a bunch of different trials already but
the most recently my mom passed away
from covid
in february she was 54 you know had no
prior
health issues um she's the
she's the outlier um and all the
statistics but uh hey man hey man
i'm sorry that happened i hate that for
you
we're uh it's it's
it was set in stone before we were we
were here yeah
oh man anyway so uh my wife is a uh
surgical trauma icu nurse yeah boy okay
and so she sees stuff like that every
day all day um
and so my question is is how do we go
about
grieving this together um you know
because i
my my career is completely different
with her she's
almost immune not immune to seeing
things like that but she grieves
a lot differently than i do and um
anyways we're just
trying to trying to figure out how to
manage that
well man i love your question and the
fact that you're asking this question to
23
24 tells me you're way way way ahead of
the game
you're you're a decade and a half ahead
of where i was man or a decade of where
i was
when i figured this stuff out man so
good for you
um a couple of things one
everybody grieves differently and the
beauty of a relationship
is holding space for the person that you
care about and love
to grieve differently than you and
continually leaning in especially where
it's uncomfortable
when you're saying can we for god's sake
just move on
this is not still a thing or you have to
shower right those some of those
frustrating moments with somebody else
saying
how how are you already over this like i
can't breathe or every time i see a
picture of my mom
my heart stops again right and so it's
just
holding space which means you have to
have
some really open and vulnerable
conversations
and those can be tough especially for
newlyweds because that's something that
you practice
along the way right and suddenly you
guys got thrown into the deep end of the
pool
uh how did you grieve your mom's death
man um
or lately uh yeah we've started too
i've got a really good group of a small
group that meets once a week and
um and so that's been one of our uh
one of my outlets of grieving was just
because i can you know it's
a group of guys we meet and uh i can be
vulnerable with and talk about
you know how i truly am feeling um
and so that's been one of my biggest
ways um
and we we hadn't really grieved it
completely yet
yeah it's still still pretty raw yeah
um is your dad still in the picture
he is um it's been real tough on him
and it's
part of me feels like i've not been able
to grieve because of his grieving
yeah um so they were
go ahead yeah go ahead and they were
they were
married for they've been together about
40 years or
so they were since they were in middle
school in high school oh
it's been uh it's been real hard on the
whole family
yeah so he's losing
yeah he lost two-thirds of himself right
yes sir yeah man like that's that's
yeah that's when you learn like you lose
the ability to breathe
and the ability to think and the ability
to make any sort of decision because
you've
those things have been intertwined in
another person and you wouldn't trade it
for the world right
but man that's an abrupt end then it's
heartbreaking and it's hard to even wrap
your head around it man
so in the same way that your wife is
gonna have to create space for you
that's gonna look different
from one another you and your dad are
gonna grieve differently too
and where that can get hard is you're
gonna feel like
i'm not grieving like he is or am i
grieving enough or he's
overdoing it or he's under doing it and
one of the ways we distract ourselves
from our own pain is by looking out into
the world
and trying to make judgments on it
right trying to say you're not doing
enough you're doing too much i can't
believe you said that leave me alone
all of those are defense mechanisms for
the
big hole that's sitting right in the
middle of our chest which is
mom was taken way way way too young
right she never got to hold her
grandkids she never got fill in the
blank man
like we had all these plans and
um did we all able to have a funeral
we were good so that that
that really put good closure to it but
uh not closure
it was a it was a way to say i love you
through a ceremony
right closure's going to take years
and if you if you leave a funeral
thinking
this should be done now then you end up
attaching
shame and frustration and it leaks out
all over the place in being short with
people and being angry and firing off
emails and not sleep in all those other
ways
because your body's still trying to
process this grief that we've got
like we've got a hey it should be over
now you get three days off of work and
get your butt back in the office right
so
um what i would challenge you with is to
find the things that help you grieve and
honor your mom
whatever that looks like if that's
writing mom a letter if that's opening
up an email account
that only you and your wife have access
to and you write your mom an email once
a week
just to say you miss her just to tell
her something funny happened i don't
know what your relationship
with there was like before this but
there's something about
the continuity there the the continue
letting continually letting some of the
stuff out in a
planned way it'll find its way out
and then back to your wife for folks who
work in trauma
you have to have a separate process for
professional
secondary trauma and your own personal
real trauma
i've seen this over and over and i've
done it myself
which is man if you live and work in the
trauma of other people for a living
it's real easy to say hey that's just a
body or
yep people die let's go ahead and set
this up
i can have some really direct frank
conversations with my friends
about people who passed away in their
world or sickness or mental health
issues
i've got to really hold space to own my
own pain
otherwise i'll blow over it and it will
build up and build up and build up and
it will bury me
and so it may be that your wife has just
rolled mom up in this season
as a yet another trauma as one is
what i do it's how i process it and what
i'll tell you is man she's going to be
burned on that job within a few years
and be really struggling with purpose
and value what i do next
yeah and i would recognize you may not
have known how long does she know your
mom
two years three years five years about
three years okay
so it's a big deal not near what it is
for you
and what she's got to learn to hold
space for is that you're grieving hard
and the guy she loves is struggling
right yeah and she does a really good
job about making sure
i'm doing okay and just asking you know
how i was emotionally that day so she
does a great job doing that
good and uh for for us it's hard because
she'll come home and you know she's a
verbal processor or
she'll start talking about her day and
um yeah
no nope yeah so listen
people who work in trauma also bury
their spouses with
i i when i whenever i'm training you
know
um medical students or counseling
students or
doing continuing ed for those groups
i'll always say don't ever
use your spouse as a garbage bin
they didn't sign up for that so if you
need somebody to talk to you about what
you've seen
you should have a group at work or
nurses whatever you process that kind of
stuff with
i've got two or three people in my life
that i could process
the actual things i saw
right i could talk to it with
dr long i could talk to it with with
sarah with
andy i could talk to a couple of my
teammates and that was about
it i remember a couple of times at a
like hanging out with my closest buddies
and say guys guess what i saw last night
and i would tell them about some
extraordinary
scene i'd and they
look like appropriately so right
like i had melted them and so i learned
hey man they didn't ask for this
that's not a cool thing to dump that on
them and so i'm never gonna do that
again so
your wife has to learn that and what i
would tell her is
that in a loving kind respectful way
at this season i can't hear about all of
the
wild things you see at work i need you
to find some friends that can hear the
trauma parts
i would love to hear about your day i
want to hear about how you're doing how
the offices go i wonder about those
things
but i can't hear about people passing
away i can't hear about the
failed catheters and the failed you know
and the
all the all the trauma that goes on
inside her role
right and i would do that in a loving
kind way so that she
can wrap her head around it
and um you still love her i still we're
still all still in this together
but at this season in the season i can't
hear that it may be that someday you
love hearing about that stuff
probably not me and my dad could talk
about that stuff but me and my mom sure
did not
my dad grew up seeing it my mom didn't i
don't talk about that stuff with my
brother with my sister
um so there's just very few people we
can talk about that
but i'd recommend writing your mom a
letter man until you miss her and that
you love her
let your wife know you're doing this and
then for the next four or five or six
months once a month when you all do your
budget for the month
when you all go over your calendar for
the month or for the week just check in
how are you doing with mom's passing i'm
still struggling
or i'm getting better things are tough
or i'm calling dad today just to check
in on him
and just so you know
man if you continue to talk about this
continue to be open continue to have a
respectful
and dignified dialogue together
that inability to breathe you'll slowly
find yourself taking deeper breaths
you're always going to miss your mom
always but it won't always hurt so bad
and at some point you'll make meaning
out of this whether it's sitting with
guys who have
experienced this you know
being a vaccine advocate whatever who
knows right
um but you'll begin to make meaning of
this and then that story will be yours
to tell
so thanks so much for the call brother
um so sorry to hear about your mom
so sorry to hear about that
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and
loud and it seems that everyone has
anxiety
i've been there and so have you it's why
i wrote this small
direct and personal book called
redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life
back i wrote this book so everyone could
read it not just science nerds like me
and my friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
let's go to sean in north carolina sean
hey what's going on man
hey john i'm glad to be on the show well
i'm glad that you called brother
what's up all right so i am a young
manager 23 years old
and i have to go and confront them
please that racist comments he made
i've initially talked to him and found
out he has a pretty homogeneous
upbringing that
influences his words he works hard but
his comments are often insensitive
okay i don't necessarily want to fire
him immediately but i have to counsel
him and talk to him and then potentially
recommend him for dismissal how do i go
about this
oh so what are some of the things
man what are you working on what's your
job what's your trade i like
construction construction okay
so what is
he talking about what's he saying he
went up to
one of his direct supervisors and
said that most black people are lazy and
don't work hard
why what what precipitated that he
oftentimes when i notice him and hear
him i don't talk to him directly too
much he is one of those people who
always just brings up
stuff he really shouldn't talk about at
work he's always bringing up just
politics and just says things that are
always out of place
and i just don't know how to go about it
he works hard but it's just his comments
consistently
are just not workplace appropriate out
of place
um do you have people of color on your
crew
yeah it's about half and it's just
causing issues in the workplace and i
don't know if i should just
recommend them for dismissal immediately
the the company policies basically i
have to counsel him twice
yeah and then i could recommend him it's
just i
it his upbringing i ate let's say listen
listen i could care less what his
upbringing is
could care less not an excuse don't care
it makes me compassionate or empathetic
but i don't care um
yeah so here's the deal i don't care how
hard of a worker somebody is
if they disparage people on my team
if they disparage potential and that may
be a direct disparagement like pointing
at somebody and saying something
insensitive and stupid not insensitive
just stupid and factually wrong some
things that hurt people
or they say something that could impact
somebody else's dad
or their mom or their brother or
whatever
i don't care how good of a worker they
are
they will unwind any sort of team morale
team support and overall team unity that
helps you get a job done
so you can be the best worker in the
world you're gonna be on my team
go work by yourself and so
uh my guess is that you sanitized that
for
me just now this guy can get pretty raw
uh absolutely and it's always just out
he's one of those people and even a
regular conversation just stuff he says
is like why would you say that
yeah um stupid comments all the time and
i feel like some of this
with me is that my fiance tells me
sometimes i treat people like projects
and i've been told by my subordinates
that sometimes i'm a little too soft on
people yep
and that's like where this comes in my
development as a young manager who's
been promoted a couple times in the last
years i feel like i have a lot of
responsibility i'm trying to deal with
this i've dealt with a sexual harassment
issue before
yeah so um
three things in in my experience
dissolve team unity faster than anything
theft and dishonesty
any sort of racial or
cultural disparagement breaking people
down
for the way they talk the way they dress
the way they just their presence their
being
right and then any sort of sexual
harassment
not being able to come to work and feel
safe or
knowing that hey this guy's holding a
ladder for me
and i wouldn't let him around my sister
i don't trust him like that
so i'm always going to be up that ladder
with one eye open does that make sense
so
those three things i have no quarter for
as a leader you're done get out of here
and what you lose in productivity from
one person you will gain in team unity
almost 100 of the time
and even then i don't care because i'm
going to do the right thing
even if it hurts me and my team
and so what i want to empower you to do
is to find those things those what i
would call
values man a construction site talk
politics
i have been on a number of constructions
especially when i was younger
man i talked in a way on a construction
site man you language flies
that's one thing that's a construction
site right that is different than
disparaging people because of the way
they look right
and so i would be really clear about who
you're going to be what kind of manager
you're going to be what kind of leader
you're going to be what you're going to
tolerate
and then man as a 23 year old you're
going to get tested right out of the
gate with some 48 year old
tradesman who's really good at what he
does who's going to lean into this 23
year old and say i dare you
and everybody's gonna be watching sean
and you know who's gonna be watching
everyone's gonna be watching
but the most important person watching
is that guy you look in the mirror
right you're right so listen
um you can hold other people's
pain and trauma right you can hold it
you cannot manage the outcome so at some
point one of those guys is going to come
in there and say hey my wife's
um really sick and you're going to say
get out of here and go be with your wife
go take care of her
and then somebody's going to follow up
two weeks later and say hey i want three
weeks off too because
and you can tell them shut your mouth
your time will come and i'll be there to
support you
right um but if that guy never comes
back
you still did the right thing okay
right but if i'm you i'd be in this
i wouldn't even be in this guy's face
i'm not gonna meet that kind of muscle
with muscle
that's that's meeting fire with fire
that's a full
frontal assault those things never work
everybody dies
that guy's gonna come into my office and
sit down at my thing and i'm gonna lean
across the desk and say
if you make another racial statement on
this site you are
finished at this company period end of
conversation
or if you have to as the hr says you
have to counsel somebody
you will say this is your one warning
you will not divide this team up you
won't treat people that way you're not
going to make stupid stereotypical
racial nonsense
crap you're not going to spread that
poison around my job site not in my
sight
go work somewhere else but they'll
tolerate that crap not here
okay you're going to disparage women on
my site get out because i'm not going to
have that because i got a mom i got a
sister
i got a wife not gonna do it and here's
what's a cool thing for a guy like you
people are your projects whenever
somebody
starts spewing poison like that on your
team
i want you to think of the other 40 guys
as your project
not that one those are the guys that you
need to keep safe
and well and make sure that they've got
a place where they can show up and work
their butt off every day
not that they all have to put up with
this one idiot right
now i've been harsh i also want to give
people
this one sliver of grace
i will call somebody in and say you may
not know this so here's your benefit of
the doubt
we don't say that here we don't talk
that here
this isn't funny here i've done that at
every single job i've ever been to
sometimes people are being jerks
sometimes people just didn't know
and um that's me using my role
and i i'd like to think of it using my
role for good and i hope you can do that
too
so wrap my head around this picture
how's that going to go you're going to
call them and then what's going to
happen next
i'm going to call them i'm going to go
over the policies some we don't tolerate
that here because
it's just going to affect everyone else
on the site it's not acceptable it's not
tolerable
and if he does it again he's getting
fired
so i want to challenge you on something
okay
on this one you have to follow policies
but don't hide behind him
okay this is a virtue and value thing
now you don't have to do this but i'd
love to see you go one extra notch and
say
i'm tired of you disparaging people on
this site
because of their race and culture
it's wrong it's not right it's not how
we treat people
and from this point forward that that
behavior is done it's over if i hear
about it again you're out of here
and then you can go back to here's the
policies and stuff but anytime somebody
starts policy with me i feel like
they're hiding from
a hard conversation and this is one that
i think is a big enough deal and then i
would loop
everybody back into that and call
everybody into a team meeting if you all
have those
and say i've addressed some of you
this will not happen here y'all can joke
around have fun i want this to be crazy
obviously i can bring kids to a
construction site right
but we're not gonna we're not doing this
does that sound good yes john thank you
for the advice on it hey man
this is one of those uh defining moments
when you're gonna find out about
yourself as a leader
as a person who takes a stand for what's
right
and for whatever it's worth brother i'm
proud of you
okay thank you all right man take care
and hey
shoot me a note back and let me know how
that conversation goes it may go
awful that dude may blow up and get in
your face and say this and that no i've
been reading about it
stick to your guns do what's right and
um
hold the line on that virtue and value
man that's awesome brother that's
awesome
all right as we wrap up today we're
gonna double back to
you know what i was gonna do social d
but we're not we're gonna go to the
best song of all time you know how i
know
because it's called the best by tina
turner off her 1989 foreign affair
album do what you're not going to do
father's day song
i don't have a i could do this the worst
song of all time and it could be a creed
song
with arms that's like a dad song isn't
it
yeah he wrote that when he had his first
kid i think oh thanks for
oh bringing a room down james giles
everybody
[Laughter]
do you have a dad song you want me to do
i mean
i have yeah there's lots of great father
songs
go for it if you're done making fun of
scott stapp having a baby
[Laughter]
what's the song give me one i mean
you've got everclear
father of mine you've got not a great
not a great representation of dads but
continue i didn't say they were good
okay sad songs about that cats in the
cradle huh
oh here's okay what's worse arms light
open or butterfly kisses by bob carlisle
um butterfly
kisses is extraordinary it's an amazing
song
kelly will you read the lyrics to
butterfly kisses uh no not in any way
shape or form will i do that that goes
against
not only my work values but my personal
values but
my personal favorite dad song papa was a
rolling stone
that's another good father song yes he
was so ladies and gentlemen here's the
deal
find your favorite dad song whether it's
talking about how awful your dad was
like ever clear
or with hearts
[Music]
or the cats in the whatever it happens
to be find yourself a good dad song
listen call your dad say and tell him
that you love him call him today and
tell him that you love them
and um for those of you whose dads
didn't show up i'm sorry
make sure that you are a part of a
marriage you're part of a
unit that's going to turn that around so
thank you so so much for joining us on
this special father's day episode
be nice to each other stay in school
don't do drugs and call your dads
take care this has been the dr john
dolone show
you